swedish soldiers and veterans pay their
respects to comrades lost in
international operations 200 years after
sweden was last officially at war this
ceremony on gotland takes place at the
start of a new era for the military
as sweden edges closer to nato combat
readiness at home has rarely been higher
up on the agenda
we are absolutely on the right track we
are reorganizing the army it is not that
big at the moment but it's
its qualities are high and with
well-trained personnel and with a lot of
nato and international experience
sweden has stepped up its military
exercises but it has some catching up to
do with fellow nato applicant finland
wilhelm agrell is a former soldier who
has spent decades publishing work on
security policy in the nordics
around 2000
sweden
bought in on the idea that there
wouldn't be any war in europe anymore
so the
territorial defense of sweden could
simply be scrapped finland never bought
in on this
they remained in the territorial defense
mode and therefore they don't have to go
back to that
one part of the defense is abandoned by
sweden was gotland the island described
as an unsinkable aircraft carrier due to
its position in the baltic its garrison
was disbanded in 2005 before being
reinstated four years ago
gotland is of great strategic importance
due to the fact that putin and russia
are clearly shown that they are willing
to use military force it is important to
have military presence and a good
military capability on the island
national conscription was also brought
back in 2018
strength and depth is where sweden and
finland really differ finland's
long-standing conscription policy means
it can put hundreds of thousands of
soldiers into the field that number's
somewhere between thirty and sixty
thousand for sweden
sweden's army air force and navy can
punch above their weight they have a
technological edge helped by a
multi-billion dollar arms industry
and an injection of cash as the military
bids to double in size
whatever their respective strengths it's
still likely to be sweden and finland's
geographical position that would benefit
nato if their application is eventually
approved
paul reese al jazeera gotland sweden